benhaim elle est nerveuse elle est
nerveuse à marocaine
regardez tout va bien toi qu'est-ce que
tu m'a inquiété est ce que tu dis viens
me voir et coutumes bah oui
donc je te présents julien quel
photographe et qui m'a contacté en fin
de semaine dernière les cas un deal qui
m'a proposé à moi qui ai moi je trouvais
ça intéressant
et voilà qui pourrait du coup de le
proposer à toi aussi tu vis en gros
l'histoire six mois je suis vachement
photographe paul machin très son sac à
dos
c'était déjà croisé il ya un moment est
donc là moi je fais des jeux là
j'aimerais bien organisé une petite
enfin une sorte de fausse paparazzade
avec jean-michel avec toi on pourrait
monter un petit truc un peu suggéré ou
même assez moche on va dans la rue là
discrètement on prend une photo ou à
vous tenez la main un petit bisou
échapper je vais arrêter ces trucs là
c'est juste mais c'est pas forcément moi
dans la miss et en plus c'est un mec
justement sa plongée en fait je demande
juste un truc
non parce que 20 ans sur la télé j'ai
pas fait une croix je pensais au stade
de toute ma life tapas 10 des tarifs non
sa vie l'agenda s'améliorer pour la ce
pour le sens bien fait pour lui c'est
dire ah bah moi je suis moi je suis
partant tu sais que cyril apprend des
blindés ça va le faire marrer justement
la firme arrive et va dire comme ça hein
pas josh freeman et si je peux me
permettre
derrière tu démens vous démentez chacun
votre tour derrière comme cette famille
derrière avec 1 300 noms mais c'est
dingue dingue
pas besoin de ça tient au plus vite soit
on pense à moi j'avais 6 ans regarde pas
parce que c'est qu'elle s'appelle créé
ninja heroes on sait très bien qu'ils me
tueront qui fait tout j'ai fait une
sorte de pseudo montage pour voir ce que
ça peut donner c'est un truc un peu
grossier je sais pas mon père du tout
c'est juste que c'est ça oui mais ça
c'est alors que c'est pas du tout c'est
faux ça sort en touche et c'est aussi
pour ton coup puisque c'est vrai ça
devient la routine avec patoche pour toi
je te dois je vais finir tu m'a fait
venir pour ça qu'il commence à les deux
émissions où je me marre parce que je
trouve que c'est il présida marrant et
non mais ho des gentils où je ne marche
pas ce que je trouve que c'est hilarant
et pour moi non c'est pas ça ou si
auchan ou là je suis en colère parce que
tu peux penser un seul instant que je
vais te dire oui à ce genre de merde
kas non tu fais pas de photos non pas
faire une petite photo ont tout petit
devant dernière comme ça ça ne vaudra
rien soleil pour te montrer ça va donner
non tu peux dire quoi ta fille bas je
veux dire que j'ai fait dire à ta fille
que tu as fait un truc qui est contre la
morale pour de l'argent c'est ça que tu
vas lui dire moi je vais me refaire
moi j'ai fait et des affaires plainte en
jetant un petit peu juste pour voir
est ce que tu feras pas de redoux
franchement je te préfère à l'époque de
ses manches soit vraiment vraiment tu
parles d'un tintin a dit est super on
voit que lui mais s'il faut c'est bon
c'est déjà sa part arrêté c'est bon à
ces mots vous bon sang
en fait si je ne trouvais pas dans non
totalement une petite photo elle sera
d'accord je continue ou pas pour nous
c'est mon manager en ce moment là les
tchèques n'ont jamais rien comme ça mais
non non je m'en fiche mais même 208 je
m'en fous à 200 mégawatts
si tu veux pas avec jean michel olivier
minne qui serait choquant la mise à me
voilà ai dit viens et je t'avais dit
j'essaie moi mais c'est le tennis a
permis de mieux alors votez supermax
about that many il suit explique george
clooney brad pitt
olivier minne jean michel jean charest
on peut pas avoir respecté ses principes
tu comprends gentiment il m'a dit c'est
la plus naïve elle a peut-être un script
et je la sais pas et je t'en veux pas
parce que de toute façon tu fais ce que
tu veux je te jure rejoignez tu sais
parce que je t'aime où es-tu là
demande à quelqu'un d'autre en tout cas
je ne serais pas avec tout 59
ici on fait à ce point patoche à 3 bien
sûr ça alors là on peut augmenter les
tarifs ainsi c'est un truc un peu quand
un bleu comme ça à 3 to see patoche le
fait aujourd'hui je fais pas la gueule
bourdon je trouve pas des gueules ou
bien souvent vision jeanne d'arc
[Applaudissements]
valérie bénaïm rejoint bravo valérie